[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار استهلوها بابرز
العلمي
انتحاريه وراء تفجير تقسيم في اسطنبول
والحصيله سته قتلى واكثر من 80 شريحه
القضاء الايراني يصدر اول حكم بالاعدام
على متظاهر ويوجه التهما مماثله لمئات
اخرين
سيطره تنضيمقراطيه حاسمه على مجلس الشيوخ
وسبعه مقاعد تفصل الجمهوريين عن اغلبيه
النواب
قضيه المهاجرين
ايطاليا باريس تهدد وروما تطالبها بتحمل
المسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
نبدا جوله التاسعه هذا المساء من اسطنبول
التي شهدت اليوم تفجيرا دمويا راحه ضحيته
سته قتلى على الاقل و 82 شرحا التفجير
الذي وقع في شارع الاستقلال المؤدي الى
ساحه تقسيم المعلم السياحي الشهيره وصفته
الدواء الرسميه التركيه بالارهابيه وفتحت
تحقيقات فوريه بالوقوف على تفاصيله
وتداعيته الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
قال ان امراه طالعه بالهجوم الذي تم
تنفيذه باستخدام قنبله قبل ان تعود
الرئاسه التركيه وتؤكد ان منفذه الهجوم
انتحاريه
كان هناك تفجير في شارع الاستقلال ووقع
قتله وجرحى اتمنى شفاء العاجل لهم وتم نقل
الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين على
التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب لم يصل لمبتغاه والعناصر التي
تحاول النيل من الوحده التركيه لن تحقق
طموحها وسينال المجرمون عقابهم
معنا من اسطنبول
الكاتب الصحافي استاذ مهند هناك
سيناريوهات عدى اليوم حول من يقف وراء هذا
التفجير من داعش الى حزب العمال
الكردستاني الى ايران التي هناك يعني
العلاقات التركيه الايرانيه
بمطبات عديده بالفتره الماضيه اي من
السيناريوهات هو المرجح اكثر
جميع المشاهدين يبدو لين انا السيناريو
التنافس الايراني بعيده الضغط الشعبي
الداخلي والضغط الاعلامي الكبير على ايران
ونظام الملاهي هناك تريد طهران ان تهرب
الى الامام من خلال تغيير الراي العاميه
سواء القنوات العالميه او العربيه على حد
سواء لكي ااه توجه الانظار الى تركيا والى
همم عمليه ارهابيه في منطقه مشتهره
بالسياح شارع الاستقلال يترابدهم يوميا ما
بين المليونين ونصف بدها ثلاثه ملايين شخص
بالتعليم همم تريد ان تهرب الى الامام من
خلال وضع المجهر على تركيا
تستطيع تواجه هذا انحراج الشعبي الداخلي
ربما تكون الادوات داعش وهمم حزب العمال
الكردستاني على حد سواء انا عندي قناعه
شخصيه
ان ايران تدعم كلا من داعش وحزب العمال
الكردستاني والذي جرى من هذا التفجير
الارهابي هو تخطيط دوله وليس تخطيط عناصر
منفرده او ذئاب منفرده هم قاموا فقط
باثبات وتنفيذ هذا المخطط الارهابي الخطير
ولكن الامن التركي همم سوف يوقع بهم كما
احبطها الكثير من المحاولات التي حاولوا
ان يعملها
منذ فتره هو من القوقاز الى البلقان وصولا
الى سوريا الى سوريا وتحديدا شمالي وشرقي
سوريا همم العمليه العسكريه التركيه كانت
جمدت بالفتره الماضيه هل ممكن ان تكون هذه
العمليه داخل اسطنبول الذريعه لاعاده
تفعيلها من جديد
لا يبدو لي على امر منفصل تركيا لا تربط
ما يجري فئه في محاولات او عمليات ارهابيه
في الداخل التركي بعمليات عسكريه خارج
البلاد الامر هناك متعلق بتفاهمات دوليه
مع لاعبين اساسيين في الملف السوري ااا
صحيح سوف ينعكس هذا اذا ما ثبتان وثبت
قراءه ان ايران هي المتورطه الاول في هذه
العمليه الارهابيه وهذا تفجير الارهابي
فان سوف ينعكس ليس فقط على العلاقات ما
بين تركيا وايران بل حتى سوف يكون هناك
تضامنا دوليا مع تركيا وسوف تكون هناك
عقوبات وهناك اعدادات وهناك الكثير من
التحركات الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه سلبا ضد
ايران اذا ما ثبت التوبه همم في ساعات
القادمه سوف تكون حاميه الوطيس سوف نحاول
او سوف نشاهد المسؤولين الاتراك وهم
يدونها ومسابقون الزمن بالفعل في هذه
الاثناء التي نتحدث فيها بسبقون الزمن
لمعرفه من قام بتخطيط هذا العمل الارهابي
نفذه لكي يقوموا بالتوجه الى المواطن
التركي
وطلاعه على ما جرى بالادله الدامغه تركيا
معتدم على سرعه التحركات الاستخباراتيه
الاميه واظن ان الساعات القادمه سوف تكون
حبله بالكثير من المعلومات التي تصل بنا
الى من قام بالتخطيط ومن قام بالتنفيذ
مفصلين والتنفي منذ العام تحديدا بالعام
2016 هناك العديد من الهجمات الارهابيه
التي هزت تركيا منها ما كان مرتبط
بالقاعده وكان هناك عفوا بداعش وكان هناك
طبعا ظروف امنيه وسياسيه مختلفه لتركيا
بتلك الاونه عن اليوم اليوم همم كيف يمكن
ان تنعكس هذه على حركه تركيا السياسيه في
الداخل والخارج
ايه يعني الضربه التي لا تقتل تقوي اليوم
ربما تستغل المعارضه التركيه ما جرى وان
تقوم بالشحن الاعلامي ضد الحكومه التركيه
وان هناك خرقا امنيا وما شابه من هذه
الكلمات ولكن حل المستوى العملي ربما تكون
هذه ربما في مصلحه الحكومه اذا ما بالفعل
كانت سريعه وهم استطاعت ان تحصر بمن نفذ
وبمن خطط اا لكي تقوم بالوصول الى الامان
فيما يتعلق طب انا المواطن التركي من جهه
بالاضافه الى ان سياساتها الخارجيه
وتحركاتها سوف تبقى على ما هي عليه بدليل
ان الرئيس اردوغان همم لم يقم بتغيير ايمن
مخططه الدوليه وقد ذهب الى قمه ال 20 همم
هي رساله واضحه بشكل اساسي الى ان تركيا
ماضيه قدم في خطوطتها ولم يعيقها لا
عمليات او تفجيرات هنا او هناك ولو كانت
في اسطنبول شكرا لك استاذ مهند اوكي اللي
هو ال- اا كاتبقى صحفي حدثت انا من
اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
افاده بلوكس لمراقبه القطاعات الانترنت
بتقيد من التواصل الاجتماعي في تركيا بعد
الانفجار الذي شهدته منطقه تقسيم وسط
مدينه اسطنبول وقال مرصد نت بلوكس لان
الشبكات الاجتماعيه التي جرى تقييدها شملت
تويتر وانستغرام ويوتيوب وفيسبوك وذلك عقب
الانفجار الذي وقع في شارع الاستقلال
واسفراء عن قتلى وشرحها
واسراء حادثه التفجير اعربت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانه المملكه باشد
العبارات للتفجير الارهابي الذي استهدف
منطقه تقسيم وسط اسطنبول وادى الى وفاه
وجرح عدد من المدنيين واكدت الخارجيه
السعوديه في بيان ان المملكه تقف مع تركيا
ضد هذا العمل الجبان معربه عن تعازيها
لذوي الضحايا والتمنيات بالشفاء العاجل
للمصابين
[موسيقى]
قال وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان القضاء
الايراني اصدر اول حكم بالاعدام على
متظاهر على خلفيه الاحتجاجات الحاليه بعد
التوجيهها الاتهام منحو 800 متظاهر جديد
في ثلاث محافظات على خلفيه الاحتجاجات
وبحسب ارقام القضاء الايراني تم توجيه
الاتهام الى اكثر من 2000 و 200 شخص نصفهم
في طهران منذ بدا الاحتجاجات وافاد موقع
ميزان التابع للقضاء الايراني بان 164
متظاهرا سيحاكمون اعتبارا من الخميس
المقبل بتهم اثاره الشغب واضاف موقع ميزان
ان المحتاجين سيحاكمون بيتوهم التامر ضد
الدوله والتحريض على القتل والدعايه ضد
النظام والسهداف قبل الامن واشار الموقع
التابع للقضاء الايراني الى ان التهام
المواجهه للمحتاجين قد تصل عقوبتها الى
الاعداء
التهديد باعدام الموقفين لم يعرقل خطى
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه التي دخلت اسبوعها
التاسع ففي وقت تتواصل احتجاجات على مقتل
مهسا امينه خرجت دعوات اخرى لاحياء ذكرى
قمع مظاهرات عام 2019 التي نددت بارتفاع
اسعار الوقود النشيطون الايرانيون دعوا
الى مظاهرات واسعه في 15 من نوفمبر الجاري
احياء لذكرى مرور ثلاثه اعوام على حمله
القمح التي لاحظهايتها الف وخمسمائه شخص
على الاقل وانتشرت دعوات للتظاهر في طهران
والاهواز ومشهد وغيرها على ان تبدا
المدارس والجامعات قبل الخروج للساحات
الرئيسيه من جهته هدد مدير الحوزات
الدينيه في ايران المحتاجين الذين يزيلون
العمائم عن رؤوس رجال الدين بالموت مضيفا
ان العمامه ستتحول الى كفنا
للمعتدين كما اعلن مسؤول في القضاء
الايرانيه عن توجيهتهامات تصل عقوبتها
للاعدام الى 11 موقوفا بالضلوعي بقتل الع
اكتر من الباسيج الشهر الماضي وتقدر منظمه
حقوقيه اعداد الايرانيين الذين قتلوا في
المظاهرات باكثر من 330 شخصا حتى الان
بينهم اثنان وخمسون طفلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اخيرا
مشهد الاحتجاجات في ايران لا يختلف بين
2019 و 2022 القمع في مواجهه التظاهرات
عنصر ثابت في المكان مع تغير الزمان الفرق
يتمثل في نفس الاحتجاجات فالسابقه ولدت
والحاليه مستمره رغم كلفه الباهظه من
الضحايا بلغه الارقام
326 شخصا على الاقل لقوا مصر من بينهم
اطفال ونساء وافقا منظمه حقوق الانسان في
ايران غير الحكوميه التي يقع مقرها في
اوسلو خلال الاحتجاجات الجاريه التي فجرها
مقتل ماسا امين على يد الشرطه الايرانيه
وقبل سنوات ثلاث سقط ازيد من 300 قتيل في
حين تحدثت مصادر اخرى عن حصيله تجاوزت
الالف ولان الذكريات لا تموت خاصه في
وجدان الشعوب دعوات من ناشطين ايرانيين
الى تظاهرات كبيره هل اسبوع المقبل لاحياء
ذكرى من دفعوا حياتهم ثمنا لها انذاك
التظاهرات المتوقعه تشمل المدارس
والجامعات والاسواق خاصه في العاصمه طهران
حتما سيكون يوما عاصفا في وجه النظام
الايراني الذي لا يتقن سوى لغه القمع في
مواجهه احتجاجات سلميه تطالب في كل مره
برحيل من قتلوا وشردوا الالاف من
الايرانيين منذ سيطرتهم على الحكم سنه
بلال الوجديني العربيه
من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان
الايرانيه حسن اراضي استاذ حسن سابدا من
موضوع الاعدام بعد ما اعلنت السلطات
الايرانيه عن اول حاله اعدام للمتظاهرين
امام هذا النموذج الوحشي الذي بدا منذ
اربعه عقود مع هذا النظام لالحاق الاذى
بالجسد الاجتماعي هل ممكن ان يؤثر على
يعني نبض التظاهرات اليوم او سيزيد من حده
هذه التظاهرات
لكم
الاحتجاجات لانه كل ما عدم النظام ايراني
او سجن كل ما يشعل النار الغضب همم الشعوب
في داخل ايران تصور كم 1000 عدم النظام
ايراني حتى الان عشرات الالاف عدم يعني
مئات الالاف في السجون همم يعني هربوا من
ماتش النظام ايراني في الخارج لكن ما زال
النظام همم ليس له اي مكان ليس له اي
شعبيه ليس له اي احترام همم في داخل ايران
وعند المواطن لذلك والغضب يزداد الغضب
يزداد عند المواطنين ورفض النظام الايراني
يزداد بل ترجم هذا الغضب يعني بالاحتجاجات
بالمظاهرات بالسحب صور من همم يعني ايضا
سقط اسقاط العمامه وكل من هذا يدل على انه
هذا الغضب تبدل الى العمل يعني الاحتفافات
هو اسقاط النظ الايراني بسبب كل تلك
الجرائم التي يرتكبها في العام 2019 كنا
نتحدث عن غضب اقتصادي معيشي بحث اليوم
نتحدث
نظام لتغيير كل يعني الحاكمين في ايران
اليوم وبالتالي المعالجه الامنيه لن تكون
يعني لن تحقق الهدف المرجو لاننا نتحدث عن
اسباب اعمق بكثير على ماذا يعول النظام
اليوم
ليس لديه ليس لديه اي بديل لا يمتلك بديل
ولا يمتلك حلول القمع والقتل والاعدامات
وتخوي في المواطنين من الجهه وايضا يعول
على انه ال- ال-
جانبه او يساعده او يعني يعقد اتفاقيات
معه حتى يستطيع على الداخل وايضا ربما من
السنه راريوهات النظام الايراني يعني همم
اثاره ازمه اقليميه او خارجيه او حتى حرب
او اشتباكات حتى يسيطر على الداخل اذا وصل
الامر الى طريق مسدود وبدات الطريق يعني
مسدود امام النظام الايراني في الداخل
يعني اعتقد هو هذا التعويل النظامي ايراني
يعني القمع والمزيد من القتل واثاره
الازمات الخارجيه من اجل تقطيع الدفاع
الماضي
الحرس الثوري ومن المؤسسات الامنيه انقلاب
على النظام في محاوله لتكرار السيناريوهات
التاريخيه التي حصلت في ايران ولكن الحرس
الذي كان من المفترض ان يكون حارس الثوره
تحول يعني
لعنوان الفساد الثوره ولكل العناوين
البشعه عن هذه الثوره ماذا ايضا يعني ذلك
الانظمه يعني الشموليه خاصه العقائديه همم
لا تمتلك الا مثل هكذا امور يعني الفساد
على انقلاب داخلي هل هل هو ممكن
احد السيناريوهات طبعا مطروحه احد
السيناريوهات طاح بالنظام الايراني هو
اللي يعني
الانقلاب العسكري الانقلاب العسكري اما
ياتي من خلال الجيش اما من خلال عناصر من
الحرس الثوري الايراني لانه ليست كل من
ينتمي الى الحرس او عضو في الحرسه والبسيج
هو يعني مؤمن بالنظام او يريد ان يحافظ
على النظام
الموجوده في داخل ايران همم الفقر دفعت
الكثير من المواطنين يعني يذهبون الى
المراكز العسكريه تجندون من اجل الحصول
على راتب وهؤلاء الذين يروح عندما يرون
انه هذا النظام وهذه الاليه القمعيه
العسكريه والامنيه تقنع المواطنين وتقمع
اهلهم بالتاكيد همم يعني يتاهلون اي فرصه
من اجل الانقلاب على هذا النظام احد هذه
السيناريوهات مطروحه جدا وخاصه يقوى هذه
السيناريو عندما يستخدم النظام الايرانيات
والمرتزقه من الخارج لقمع المواطنين وهذا
ما يدفع العسكريه الداخليه الايرانيه عن
تمنع مثل هكذا استمرار القتل وراحت
السيناريوهات هو ربما الانقلاب على النظام
والا طاح بهجه
النظام الاساسي وليس النظام الفقير شكرا
لك استاذ حسن راضي البحث في الشان
الايراني حدثنا من لندن
شنت ايران هجوما على الرئيس الفرنسي بسبب
عقده لقاء مع نشطات ايرانيات باريس واعتبر
الخارجيه الايرانيه اللقاء
لمسؤوليات فرنسا الدوليه وكان مكرونه كاد
ان فرنسا تقدر وتنظر باحترام لاحتجاجات
الشعب الايراني ياتي ذلك في وقت ارتفع
فيها عدد المعتقلين الفرنسيين في ايران
الى سبعه بعد اعتقال فرنسيين اثنين امس
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الجيش الاوكراني ينزع الفا من الالغام
التي تركتها القوات الروسيه في خرسون
[موسيقى]
بمستشفيات المواساه تشخيص وعلاج جميع
امراض الدم والاورام للكبار والاطفال
العلاج الكيميائي الطب النووي امراض الدم
والاورام وامراض المناعه والغدد اللمفاويه
بكفاءات طبيه متميزه المواساه خبره تنبض
الثقه بعد غزوهم بغرب اوروبا وسيطرته
عليها وفي ذروه قوته وثيقته بنفسه كان
متاكدا بانه خطير ليقود المانيا للسيطره
على العالم وبعد فشل مفاوضاته مع موسكو
قرر اجتياحها وثائقي يروي قصه اكبر غزو
بريه في التاريخ
صعود النازيين بارباروسا الجمعه الواحده
بعد منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تسونامي الجمهوري او
مفهوم الهزيمه الانتخابيه التي كان يعملها
الجمهوريون لبايدن والحزب الديمقراطي فقط
فمع فوز السيناتور الديمقراطيه الحاليه
كافرين كورتاز ماستو بفارق بسيط على
منافسها الجمهوري ادم لاكاستال همم في
نيفادا باتت الديمقراطيون يمتلكون
الاغلبيه بمجلس الشيوخ وخمسون مقعدا
لديمقراطيين مقابل 49 للجمهوريه فبعدني
بعد كلمه الفصل او الحسن تمسكها ولايه
جورجيا بجوله اعاده انتخاب في السادس منذ
سابر المقبل ولكن ماذا قد تقدم ولايه
جورجيا مقعد جورجيا الذي يميل حاليا
للمرشح الديمقراطي رافاييل وورد وان ذهب
للديمقراطيين ايضا يصبح لهم الاغلبيه
بواحد وخمسين صوتا وهنا سيحظى
الديمقراطيون بميزه اضافيه في اقرار
مشاريع قوانين دوده ومثيره للجدل يسمح
باجازاتها باغلبيه بسيطه من الاصوات بدلا
من ال60 صوتا اللازمه لمعظم القوانين كما
سيحافظ بيض على قدره تاكيد مرشحيه
القضائيين وتعييناته الاداريه لكن في حال
ذهب المقعد للمرشح الجمهوري هيرتشيل ووكر
سيصبح مجلس الشيوخ منقصما منصفا بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريه حينها تكسر
التعادل نائبه الرئيس كامل لاهرس باستخدام
صوتها وتقلب النتيجه لصالح حزب هذه
الديمقراطي وبالتالي العوده للمربى الاول
اي الحال قبل انتخابات التجديد النصفي
[موسيقى]
بسبب هذه النتائج في الانتخابات النصفيه
بدا الجمهوريون بتوجيه اصابع الاتهام
لرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب محملين اياه
المسؤوليه
السابق دونالد ترامب في حملات المرشحين
الجمهوريين ام الاقتتال الداخلي بين اعضاء
الحزب هو ما افشل خطه اكتساح المد الاحمر
للصناديق اقتراع الكونغرس
هزيمه تسببت باحباط الجمهوريين من نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه عند الحديث عن ابرز
الخاسرين في مجلس الشيوخ رغم دعم ترامب
لهم
ادمنت عن ولايه نيفادا وبليك ماسترز عن
ولايه ارينا ومحمد اوز عن ولايه بن سلمان
حتى مقاعد مجلس النواب لم تسلم من الفشل
رغم الاقتراب من حصد الاغلبيه فالنتيجه لم
تكون كاسحه
تلك النتائج المخيبه لامال الجمهوريين
فتحت الباب للتساؤل حول مستقبل الرئيس
السابق ترامب السياسيه ومواقف اعضاء حزبه
المتضاربه من وجوده على الساحه السياسيه
ولاعبه ادوار المستقبليه كانت نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه اكبر مؤشرين على ان
ترامب لا ينبغي ان يكون المرشح الجمهوريه
عام 2024 كثير من الناس يريدون دفنه ترامب
وارفيه في قبر لكنه مازال فوق الارض ولديه
كثير من النفوذ السياسي بين الناخبين داخل
الحزب
هنالك ايضا مخاوف من دخول الحزب الجمهوري
في دوامه الفوضى الداخليه فقبل اشهر من
الانتخابات النصفيه هاجم الزعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ السيناتور مج
ماكونل اختيارات ترامب لعدد من المرشحين
ودعمهم في السباقات التمهيديه للحزب لكن
ما كونيل نفسه تعرض للانتقاد من قبل بليك
ماسترز الخاسر في سباق اريزونا والذي اتهم
من كونيل بانه السبب في خسارته بعد ان وجه
اموال الحزب لدعم مرشحه جمهوريه في الاسكا
ضد مرشحه جمهوريه اخرى في اطار الصراع
الداخليه في الحزب
بينما يتناحر الجمهوريون فيما بينهم صعد
اسم الجمهوري رمز سانتس الذي فاز بمنصب
حاكم فلوريدا كاحد اشد منافسي الرئيس
ترامب وصاحب الحظوظ الاكبر حسب التوقعات
بان يسعى لخوض انتخابات الرئاسه عام 2024
حسين يعني كيف يمكن ان تغير نتائج جورجيا
من النتائج الرسميه بالساعات والايام
المقبله وكيف ستنعكس النتائج حتى الساعه
على القوانين على التعيينات وعلى كل
الملفات بيد الرئيس
تحيه لك ليال في الحقيقه دوله الاعلام هي
تقسيم حاصل تزيد النفاذها الديمقراطيون
عبر مرشحهم
انورناب
ستزيد عن الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ ولكن
الان السيطره هي الديمقراطيين
هناك من يقول بان الجمهوريين سيف يفعلون
كل ما بوسعهم ليحصلوا على مقعد جورجيا
يستعيدوه حقيقه لكي يعودوا عن خسرتهم
ويعود الى المربع الاول قبل الانتخابات 50
50 همم اما تاثير ذلك على على ما سيجري
همم او على سياسات بيضا بطبيعه الحال همم
نزلنا ننتظر الى من ستؤول الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب هناك من يرجح طبعا ان يفوز
جمهوريه باغلبيه وسيطه في مجلس النواب
واذا اذا تم ذلك سيواجه الرئيس مشاكل مع
اجنده السياسيه لاننا نعرف ان مجلس النواب
هو من عنده تبدا الميزانيات المتعلقه
بالمشاريع الكبرى فاذا لم يمررها هذا
سيكون هناك مشكله كبيره ولكن في المقابل
سيطرت الديمقراطيه على مجلس مساعد مدن في
موضوع التعيينات القضائيه مع السياسه
الخارجيه اكثر لان هذا من اختصاص مجلس
الشيوخ بشكل اكبر همم طبعا هو في ايه في
في ضمن ذلك بيكون ذلك همم نستطيع ان نقول
الان بانك الديمقراطيين تنفس الصعداء
اخيرا بعدها
فازوا بمنه بدر
شاك شوبر اليوم وهو زعيم الاغلبيه
الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ
بعد تصويت وتبري يعني الديمقراطيين
ولسياساتهم التي يتهمونها الجمهوريه لانها
تسببت بال همم
تضخم وايضا بالوضع الاقتصادي صعب خصوصا
تحدث عن افضل نتائج منذ 20 عام
للديمقراطيين بالانتخابات نصفيه حسين كيف
يتعاطى اليوم الاعلام الامريكي مع
الانتقادات للرئيس ترامب بموضوع دعمه
للمرشحين وبافشال يعني خطط الجمهوريين
الانتخابيه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل بده يومين مبلغ حتى ما اعلان نتيجه
نيفادا كان هناك
اذا تبعنا القنوات الامريكيه المؤيده
لجمهوريين مثل فقس نيوز التي كانت تستضيف
ضيوفا ينتقدون ترامب ويلمونه على ما جرى
يقولون انه رشح مرشحين ليست لديه خبره
كافيه لخوض نيمار
طبعا القنوات
التابعه للجمهوريه لم تنتقل ترامب بشكل
مباشر هي نفسها ولكن كانت تسني مثلا على
همم بسنتس وهو على المنافس المحكمه
الانتخابات
[ضحك]
برافو على من رشحه والذين تحالفوا الله
قال كما قال معتبرا ان ال ال الشعب
الامريكي الناخب الامريكي كما يريد افكارا
ويريد المستقبل ولا يريد ان من الماضي
ولكن فين المصنع من هناك في داخل الحزب
الجمهوري من يدافع عن الترام مثل الذي قال
انه من الخطا ان يلقى بالنوم على شخص واحد
ايضا همم جاي بانز هو همم نائب جمهوري في
مجلس النواب قال انه لم يكن مترشح بهذه
الانتخابات ليقع لهم عليه هناك جدل في
الحزب الجمهوري في الحقيقه يعكس الى حد
كبير انقسام سنراه اكثر من هذه الايام
القادمه ان هناك الان مطالب اولا بان لا
يعلن تنشحه للانتخابات
هذا الانقسام كيف ينعكس على ملف الرئاسه
خصوصا ان ترامب اجل اعلان الترشيح
ليال
يقولون ان
النتائج التي حدثت الان في مجلس الشيوخ
كان جيده لبيض لكي يترشح وهنا دعوات من
نانسي في درس اليوم وايضا من من
اليزابيثات واحده رئيس مجلس النواب واحد
هي سيناتور وايضا كانت سلبيا بالنسبه
لترامب هذه النتائج من المحكمه لم تؤثر
عليه ولكن من يعرف
رايه بسهوله حتى الان لم يعني اجر ربما
اجر الاعلان ولكن هل همم ازال الفكره من
راسيه هذا امر سننتظر على القادم من
الايام لنعرف ولكن كما قلت الدعوات تزايد
له من داخل كتب الجمهوري هناك من يقول ان
هذه النتائج على يجب ان جبنا عليها
للابتعاد عندنا الاطراف الحزب اكبر من
دونالد ترامب ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك من
يقول ان الرجل ليس ذنبه ما حدث لطالبونه
بان يزور مثلا جورجيا ليست الى الى جانب
عرس الوكر
ان ترامب
ماليا لكي يفوز بانتخابات
اخرى شكرا لك احسن الطوب مراسل العربيه
حدثنا من فيرجي
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع البريطانيه بنواس انه
سيكون من السخافه اعتبارا روسيا خاسره
للحرب وقال في تصريحات التايمز ان روسيا
مازالت بعيده عن الاستسلام في اوكرانيا
واشار الى ضروره استغلال الزخم العسكري
الراهن وتوجيهي لمصلحه حسن النصر
لاوكرانيا
الف جندير مع الياتهم لكن اثارهم المزروعه
بالالغام تؤرقوا فرحه الاوكرانيين
واحتفالاتهم بانتزاع النصر الصعب عقب
السعاده القوات الاوكرانيه للمدينه
الواقعه الجنوبي البلاد حفت الشرطه سكان
خرسون على التحرك بحذر معلنتا ابطال مفعول
نحو الفي عبوه ناسفه حتى اللحظه
الاحتفالات باستعاده ما يقارب ستنا بلده
لم تخفي الدمار الكبير الجاسم على المدينه
الاوكراني دمر الروس كل البنا التحتيه
الاساسيه وما يشمله ذلك من اتصالات
وامدادات مياه تدفئه وكهرباء
المحرره من القوات الروسيه تعاني نقصا في
المياه والادويه والطعام وهي بانتظار
الامدادات الطريقه طبعا مشاهدينا القوات
الروسيه لم تغادر قبل ان تتاكد من تدبير
كل ما يمكن تدميره ما يمكن ان يخدم القوات
الاوكرانيه نحو الضفه الاخرى وتقدمها نحو
هذه الضفه من نهر النيبرو فقد اظهرت صور
انهيار جسر انتونيسكي المعبر الرئيسي من
خرسون الى الضفه الشرقيه لدني برو التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا والستر جحاتا بتدمير
القوات الروسيه للطريق وجسر السكه
الحديديه المقيمين فوق نهر النيبرو خلال
العمليه وخلال عمليات الانسحاب اما سد
نوفا كخوفك الذي يبعث 58 كلم شمال شرقي
خرسان فتعرض للضرر ايضا ما يرفع مستوى خطر
تعرض المدينه للفيضات يعيش اذا في خرفان
حاليا قرابه السبعين الى 80,000 شخص
مقارنه بعدد سكان هذه المدينه قبل الحرب
الذي كان يبلغ ثلاثه وعشرين الف سنه وبعد
الانسحاب اي الانسحاب الروسي تامل المدينه
احتضن عوده اهلها واهلها مشددا الى هذه
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
معنى مكياج
السابقه يعني هذا القرار العسكري بايطار
سياسي اقول بايطار سياسي بعد كل التصريحات
والتسريبات الامريكيه عن محادثات وعن يعني
حديث اوكراني روسي للسلام هل هذه المبادره
التي حصلت او اذا سميت انسحاب تكتيك روسي
من هذه المنطقه كيف سينعكس على الملف
السياسي تحديدا بموضوع المفاوضات
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته بصراحه
سؤالكم الجميله جدا نحن نناقش هذا السؤال
كمان هنا في اوكرانيا ولكن كما
اعلن السيد الان من المستحيل اي مفاوضات
مع
بوتن ان شروط اوكرانيه هي استعاده
اراضي اوكرانيه بعض ذلك من الممكن مفاوضات
مع روسيا هو خاصه عن تعويضات التي روسيا
سوف تدفع
يعني هذا مهم جدا ناس لتصريحات تقريبا
ثاني وزير خارجي اوكرانيابا
قوات مصالحه اوكرانيه عندي خبر جميل بان
اليوم قوات مصالحه وكريميه بدات تحرير
المنطقه الشرقيه ضفت شرقيه من اتجاه حاكين
برج واليوم اوكرانيا حرارت الجيش اوكرانيا
حرر 3 كوره
[موسيقى]
اساسيه ومنها كهرباء ومنها همم
تقريبا 10 ايام بدون كهرباء بدون اداره
ااا سكان مدينه خيرسون عندنا الشوايه
الجديده من روسيا سوف تقاسف هذه المدينه
اخرصون من ضيفه الشرقيه كمان معروفه بان
روسيا ظهرت عدد كبير من الالغام كيما داخل
مدينه خيرسون وخارج في مدينه خرسون كمان
هي حاطه السيارات
بالرغم من هذا الانسحاب الروسي ولكن 70%
من منطقه الكبرى ما زالت تحت السيطره
الروسيه وهم معا انسحابهم الى شرق نهر
النيبرو ايضا هناك يعني صعب على القوات
الاوكرانيه المقاتله بعد هذا كيف ينعكس
هذا على مسار الصراع بين الطرفين في
الاشهر المقبله هل هناك تجميد نوعا ما
وعمليات محدوده
بصراحه الان تكون اي تجميد عن اليقين وكما
ان كل ده وكاني بغداد هجوم مضاد تامين
معروفه بان اوكرانيا من الممكن سوف تهاجم
عليها مدينه
حافظ
الشرقيه محافظه
كبيره من قواتها في هذه المنطقه
لهذا تقريبا 180 كم من مدينه مدينه
الشرقيه
عنيفه دمويه جدا في محافظه ظفوري جميل
الان التي موجوده للمعارك في منطقه
امن القرن الذي كان اساس بقى العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه وخصوصا تامين المياه
والامن لهذه المنطقه هل ممكن ان تذهب
الثياب الى عمليات بالعمق بعمق هذه
المنطقه والتضييق على القرض
من الضروري بان سوف تكون
ولكن انا اعتقد بان اول ان يجب ان
الاستعاده شبه جزيره
تحت القوات المسلحه اكرهنيه وبعدين نحن
سوف
نقدمها شرقيه تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي
وتمشي من
الديب مباشره الى همم
ولكن على كل حال
شديد همم معارك ستكون عنيفه بوت ان هو لا
يعرف بالاستلام بصفه عامه وهو حتى
مفاوضات عليها شروط شروط هذا الاعتراف كل
مناطق المحتله بانها روسيه هو كمان لحظه
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن
بصراحه كل هذه شروط روسيه غير مقبوله يعني
شكرا لك
مشاهدينا قبل الذهاب الى الفاصل سنعرض لكم
هذه الصوره التي قال الاعلام التركي انها
للمراه الانتحاريه التي فجرت نفسها في
ساحه تقسيم وسط اسطنبول اذا هذه الكاميرا
او الصوره التي التقطتها الكاميرات
كاميرات المراقبه والتي اعلنت عنها وسائل
الاعلام التركيه بانها تعود للامراه التي
فجرت نفسها في الهجوم الانتحاري الذي حصل
اليوم في منطقه التقسيم في شده الاستقلال
والتي نتج عنها سته قتله حتى الساعه واكثر
من ثمانينحه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ترقب للقاء بايدنج على هامشي قمه العشرين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الخلاف حول استقبال
سفينه اوشن فايكنج للمهاجرين غير الشرعيين
نسخه مستحدثه من توترات حصلت قبل اربع
سنوات بين كل من فرنسا وايطاليا لكن النهج
المتشدد لرئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه الجديده
جورجيا ميلوني زهدها حده او زادها حده ففي
اول خلاف على منذ تسليمها السلطه انتقدت
مليون رد فعل فرنسا الذي وصفته بالعدواني
وغير المبرر رفضه مزاعم فرنسيه بان
حكومتها تتهرب من مسؤولياتها للنقل
المهاجرين عبر البحر الاسود
الرد الايطالي جاء بعد اتهامات من
الخارجيه الفرنسيه واجهتها لروما بالاخلال
بالالتزامات الاوروبيه وعدم احترام
القانونين الدولي والبحري وهددتها بمواجهه
العواقب من جهتها استنكرت سلطات روما
التهديدات الفرنسيه المباشره لها مبديه
مخاوفها من ان تشمل الاجراءات الانتقاميه
تقييد وصولها لاموال الاتحاد الاوروبي
المخصصه للتعافي من كورونا وكانت ايطاليا
رفضت استقبال سفينه تديرها منظمه خيريه
تحمل نحو 230 مهاجرا انقاذهم في البحر ثم
شكرت لاحقا فرنسا
[موسيقى]
التدين الفرنسي اعقبه بيان من اربع دول
اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي حول قدرتها على
ابتعاب المهاجرين غير الشرعيه ايطاليا
واليونان وقبرص ومالطا اكدت رفضها لفكره
ان دخول او دول الدخول الاولى هي نقاط
الهبوط الاوروبيه الوحيده الممكنه
للمهاجرين غير الشرعيه البيان الرباعي
اضاف ان عدد المهاجرين الذين استقبلتهم
دول اخرى اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي لا
يمثل سوى قدر صغير للغايه من العدد الفعلي
للوافدين غير الشرعيين الدول الاربعه
ادانت عمليات السفن الخيريه الخاصه التي
تعمل باستقلاليه تامه عن سلطات الدوله
المختصه لانتشال مئات المهاجرين الذين يتم
انقاذهم في البحر فالحكومه الايطاليه
الجديده بقياده اقصى اليمين دخلت في
مواجهه منذ اسابيع مع منظمات انسانيه تنقذ
المهاجرين وسطى ووسط البحر المتوسط حيث
ترى رو مع ان الدول التي ترفع السفن علمها
يجب ان تاخذ المهاجرين وليس ايطاليا وهو
موقف تعارضه بشده الجماعات الانسانيه
والخبراء القانونيين ونشطاء حقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من روما حسن ابو حرفوش رئيس
دائره الهجره في روما استاذ حسن يعني امام
حكومه يمنيه لديها خطاب علني ضد المهاجرين
وامام مزايدات اليمين الفرنسي في الداخل
على الرئيس الفرنسي كيف تتوقعون ان يتم
التعاطي بهذا الملف
يعني مساء الخير لكم مساء الخير للجميع
العربيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي في الوقت الحاضر لانه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ترك ايطاليا لوحدها
بالاخص يعني حتى ممكن انه نرى من بدايه
السنه
مهاجر دخله الاراضي الايطاليه ولم يدخل
سوا 250 او 230 بعيد السفينه السفينه الذي
تحمل العالم من النرويجي وهي التفكير ان
انا نروج
في الاتحاد الاوروبي فيه ذلك القانون
البحري القانون البحري او القانون الدولي
يقول انه ترفع اي علم هي مسؤوله عن
المهاجرين
وهيدي اصبحت خلينا نقول اصبح هذه السفن
التكسيات اصبحت سفن يعني تنقل المهاجرين
غير الشرعيه
3000 و4,000 او 5000 دولار لا يصلي
للشواطئ الايطاليه اي الدوله الايطاليه
ليس لديها القدره لاستيعاب هذه همم الوقود
الكبير المهاجرين
السلطات او الدوله الايطاليه ماذا عن
قانون اعاده التوطين الذي كان طبق مرحله
منه في العام 2019 والذي يعني ينص على ما
كنت تقوله بتقسيم عدد المهاجرين بين الدول
الاوروبيه ولا تتحمل دوله واحده كل
الالعاب
يا اختي العزيزه نحنا عم نقول عم نحكي من
290,000 يعني اليوم الدوله الفرنسيه ليش
ليش الشرق بيني وبين فرنسا لان الدوله
الفرنسيين
اخضعت سفينه اوشن للدخول المرفا عسكري
دخلت الى اول مره اول مره لاول مره سفينه
ااا سفينه تدخل الى مرفا عسكري وقامت
السلطات سمعيني الو
فقط
يمكنك ان تكمل
يمكن
منتخب اوك رجعت الصوره
لاي انسان الدخول
الصوت والصوره حسن الان حسن ابو حرفوش من
روما حدثنا رئيس دائره الهجره في روما
شكرا لك
شبكه بي بي سي البريطانيه بعبور اكثر من
40 الف مهاجر القناه للانجليزيه في قوارب
صغيره خلال العام الحالي واوضحت الشبكه ان
هذا العدد هو الاعلى منذ البدء باحتساب
اعداد المهاجرين الذين وصلوا الى بريطانيا
في عام 2018 وفي العام الماضي وصل ثمانيه
وعشرون الفا
و526 شخصا الى جنوب بريطانيا بين ما وصل
اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخص عام 2020 وتامل
الحكومه البريطانيه في ان تؤدي خطتها
لارسال بعض المهاجرين الى رواندا الى ردع
الناس عن عبور القناه بدورها اشارت
الحكومه البريطانيه لان المحادثات بشان
صفقه مع فرنسا ستتعلق بالنقاط التي تعبر
منها الزوارق الصغيره للقناه للانجليزي
اصبحت في مراحلها النهائيه
[موسيقى]
زعيمه اقوى اقتصادين في العالم سيلتقيان
الاسبوع المقبل على هامشي قمه العشرين في
اندونيسيا
على موعد مع ساعات من الحوار المعقد ستطرح
فيها الكثير من المشاكل الخلفيه التي
احتدمت في الاشهر الماضيه خاصه بعد زياره
نانسي بيلوسي الى تايوان ومن هذه الجزيره
تحديدا سيبدا الحوار فبكين كشفت عملياتها
العسكريه حول تايوان قبيله اللقاء المرتقب
في رساله باننا لن نتنازل عن مبدا الصين
الواحده وعلى واشنطن الالتزام بذلك في
المقابل يضعوا بايضا مجموعه من الاولويات
التي يريد من الصين التعاون فيها بدءا من
اوكرانيا فواشنطن طالب بكين في اكثر من
مناسبه بوقف دعمها لموسكو واتخاذ موقف صار
ضد الحرف يؤكرانيا الخطوط الحمراء التي
يضعها كل من الرئيسين يريد توضيحها في
اللقاء مع شيء دون ترك اي مجال اهميه وهذا
اللقاء تاتي في انها المره الاولى التي
يلتقي فيها بايدن واتشي كرئيسين وجها لوجه
فجولات السابقه من المفاوضات كانت
افتراضيه وتبقى المنافسه الاقتصاديه بما
فيها صناعه الرقائق الالكترونيه من اهم
المسائل العالقه والتي يسعى الرئيسان
لتحقيق المكاسب فيها كل من جانبه وبحسب
مصالح بلاده طبعا
[موسيقى]
حضرت مديره صندوق النقد الدولي من ان
المنافسه بين الولايات المتحده والصين قد
تؤدي الى تفتيت الاقتصاد العالمي ونبهت
مديره صندوق النقد الدولي بان الاقتصاد
العالمي يواجه خطر الانكماش بنسبه 1.5%
على اساس ثانوي اذا استمر الانقسام الحليب
في التنافس الاقتصادي
تعاهدت كل من الولايات المتحده واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه برد قوي وحازم على اي
اختبار النووي السابع قد تجريه كوريا
الشماليه كما تعاهد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بنشر كامل القدرات بما فيها القدرات
النوويه للدفاع عن حلفاء واشنطن
تتصاعد المخاوف الامنيه المتعلقه
بالاستثمارات الصينيه في الموانئ الخارجيه
مع اكتساب شركات صينيه المزيد من الحصص في
مراكز الشحن حول العالم وفقه محللين
امريكيين
الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم ولاعب
اساسي في الاقتصاد العالمي تخوض طموحا
بحريا متصاعدا يواجهم خوف امنيه خارجيه
استراتيجيه بكين الاقتصاديه لا تقتصر على
الاستثمارات الماديه فالخط الواضح الذي
تنتجه الصيني يتمثل باستخدام مزدوج
للموانئ الخارجيه
الشركات الصينيه قامت بتوسيع استثماراتها
في الموانئ الاجنبيه في السنوات الاخيره
بحسب مجله ايكونو ميسي
2010 و 2020 استثمرت الصين ما يصل الى 20
مليار دولار في الموانئ الاجنبيه حيث
تمتلك حصصا في عقود ايجار او امتيازات في
95 ميناء اجنبيه وفقا بحثا من الكليه
الحربيه البحريه الامريكيه وجامعه انديانا
فيما مرت اكثر من سبعه وعشرين بالمئه من
تجاره الحاويات العالميه العام الماضي عبر
محطات تمتلك فيها شركات الرائده في الصين
وهون كونج حصصا مباشره اما معركه الصين
فكانت في المانيا بعد ان سمحت الحكومه
الالمانيه لشركه كوسكو الصينيه بشراء حصه
تبلغ نحو 25% في مرفا بهمبرج الذي يعد
اكبر موانئ البلاد امر اثار حينها عاصفه
من الانتقادات والتساؤلات حول دوافع
القرار الالمانيه فسرت الصفقه انذاك بانها
جزء من سلسله صفقات صينيه تستهدف السيطره
على قطاعات من البنيه التحتيه الاوروبيه
بهدف استكمال مبادره الحزام والطريق التي
ترمي الى احياء طريق الحرير الصينيه
القديمه اما الولايات المتحده فترى من
تمدد الصين بشبكه الموسعه في موانئها
اجنبيه مؤشرا على وجود مخاوف عده منها ما
يتعلق باكتساح الصين سوق البضائع العالميه
وان تستخدمها كثره للوصول لمعلومات حول
نقاط ضعف في سلسله توريد لدى المنافسين
الا ان المخاوف الامنيه هي الهاجس الاول
واشنطن حيث يمكن ان تسهل الاستثمارات
الصينيه في وانا اجنبيه الطريقه امام بكين
خدمه الجوانب العسكريه البحريه لها دون
الحاجه الى بناء نظام قواعد متطورا بشكل
سريع وهو امر تنفيه الصين الرافضه تسسيسه
طموحها الاقتصاديه روان حمزه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اكدت وكاله رويترز ان تويتر الغت نحو
اربعه الاف 1500 وظيفه لمتعاقدين ومقاولين
مع الشركه بشكل احادي ومن طرف واحد
[موسيقى]
قالت شركه تسلا الامريكيه لصناعه السيارات
انها ستساعد الشرطه الصينيه في التحقيق في
حادثه تصادم باحدث سياراتها من طراز واي
بعد ما افادت تقرير اعلاميه محليه بان
شخصين لقيا حدفهما واصيب ثلاثه اخرون
عندما فقد السائق السيطره على السياره في
اقليم جنوبيه
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
انتحاريات وراء تفجير تقسيم في اسطنبول
والحصيله سته قتلى واكثر من ثمانين جريحا
القضاء الايراني يصدروا اول حكم بالاعدام
على متظاهر ويوجه التهما مماثله لمئات
اخرين
سيطره ديمقراطيه حاسمه على مجلس الشيوخ
وسبعه مقاعد تفصل الجمهوريين عن اغلبيه
النواب
قضيه المهاجرين تفجر خلافا فنسيا ايطاليا
باريس تهدد وروما تطالبها بتحمل المسؤوليه
التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه مستمره
كما كل ليله